her whole thing is I get so drunk I
don't remember who I slept with my
diaphragm fell out that's pretty much
hurt her stick I think she can be funny
sometimes but that is her bit that's her
act
it's like senior winces sorry tonight
tonight only it's a vagina
did this thing on Amy Schumer last week
in the rape situation of social justice
where your leftists who are encouraging
rape culture by being complicit with the
hashtag movements and not notifying the
proper authorities I think somewhere in
there I may have taken some jabs at Amy
Schumer's physical appearance that's
surprising doesn't sound like you it
doesn't sound like something I would do
at all so I got some comments and emails
saying hey hey why do you feel the need
to [ __ ] shame or fat shame why do you do
this and hurt with your audience here's
the thing there is no slut-shaming
culture there is no fat shaming culture
people need to understand this they
throw it out there because you make a
joke about Lena Dunham being
unattractive and fat the reason someone
might [ __ ] shaming me Schumer remember
she got so mad when a fan came up and
took a picture said hey spent the night
with Amy Schumer but that's not the
first time she heard that and she's
going how dare you call someone you
don't know a [ __ ] it's not slut-shaming
it's a reaction from the public to
someone who has made their entire living
off set your stopwatch someone who
portrays himself as a [ __ ] fat drunken
stupid is no way to go through life
stuff
the whole thing is I get so drunk I
don't remember who
my diaphragm fell out that's pretty much
hurt her stick I think she can be funny
sometimes but that is her bit that's her
act
it's like senior winces all right
tonight so that's not only it's a vagina
that's Amy Schumer's bit do you know
senior you don't even know senior winces
so it's a reaction by someone saying
okay you're portraying yourself as a
[ __ ]
this is your stick I'm going to go along
with it and now I'm annoyed with the
sluttiness you don't get to be offended
that someone thinks you're [ __ ] Lena
Dunham Lena Dunham has openly talked
about and as stood before dozens let's
be happy maybe not thousands and I said
you know our show was designed to I
really want to push this idea the
boundaries of what people think is is
traditionally beautiful okay
do that but you don't get to be offended
when people have the gall to insinuate
that you are not traditionally beautiful
or like a test holiday remember that
oversized model who we talked about Oh
Lord
and forget I don't I don't dislike this
isn't fat shaming it is a reaction to
someone demanding that you praise their
body saying hey hey look at me I am
proud of my body and people saying well
maybe maybe you shouldn't be proud of
your body it's a reaction to you making
a living off of your body this is Amy
Schumer were were your barista at
Starbucks right you wouldn't walk up to
but listen here you little Stay Puft
Marshmallow looking [ __ ] you wouldn't
do that
because you don't know her but if she
was at Starbucks saying oh my gosh I
slept with a bunch of guys last night
testing hot material you probably say
hey you're my baristas kind of [ __ ] I
never knew that about my barista I don't
know about when are touching my cold
brew same thing with Lena Dunham listen
by the way with Lena Dunham if you my
criticisms with Lena Dunham are not
based on the unkempt self-admitted
filthy exterior of the real body
it's everything that's inside it is the
the soul of Lena Dunham that I have a
problem with it's just easy - also it
happens to be wrapped in a package that
it's all discussed if none of it is good
and here's the deal what really bothers
me with a [ __ ] shaming and fat shaming
thing just because you feel as though
you're a more victimized class you don't
get to have the corner on it so a good
example is I was just at a mall recently
Lane Bryant they have one of these these
plus-sized models now and they have earn
real women dollars clothes for real
women is what they say don't act like
you're not marginalizing people so what
are they saying with this my wife's not
a real woman my mom is not a real woman
my mother-in-law isn't a real woman
nearly every guy I know who's married to
a real woman is in fact a married to a
figment of their imagination because
these women aren't plus-sized so they're
simply deciding to discriminate against
women who are smaller than them by the
way while we're talking about that I
guarantee you there are more real women
who are closer in size to runway models
or fashion magazine models than Tess
Holliday and let's take it a step
further I guarantee you there are more
real women within the proper perimeters
of Health closer to the size of more
traditional models not saying that I
want to need to look like that but you
don't get to have the corner and
victimization because you chose to be
overweight I immediately regret this
decision that's what bothers me about it
and when you make a career on it it is
totally fair game and especially because
we have an obesity problem and we have a
diabetes problem in this country I think
when you cross that realm of health it
is within the fair boundaries of
criticism something else
same thing with diseases we've talked
about this listen I'm sorry mister that
you decided to have unprotected anal sex
with bearded bikers and a truck stop and
you got AIDS that's horrible
I wouldn't wish it on anybody who has
unprotected anal sex with bearded bikers
and truck stops
I wouldn't between the dirty needle use
I watched rent I know what I'm talking
about
[Music]
will someone care
[Applause]
but you don't get to have the corner on
diseases aids get so my kitties it gets
so much more funding than all these
cancers or type 1 diabetes that the kid
didn't sign up for just because you
scream the loudest whether it's with
dildos on campus or it's about being
offended that someone insinuated you
aren't good-looking doesn't mean that
you deserve to have the corner on
victimhood feels and why do you double
down at listen I'm not doubling down on
it I'm not doubling down on fat shaming
or slut-shaming if you make a career off
of it and you thrust it in front of
peoples but you know what else I have a
problem with it wrote about this
professional victimhood is America's
fastest-growing business that's why you
have Shawn king and Rachel Dolezal
competing to be black dyes amy schumer
and lena dunham ininin female comics
competing as to who was raped more but
never came forward to the cops because
it's the best way to get your name in
the headlines in the absence of talent
or wit if you liked this video do not
click the subscribe button below my face
or the boxes next to me if you do you
will be very sorry